we have to leave you with some good
vibes for the weekend and today we're
getting some help from besties andrew
garfield and jamie dornan the pair
joined james corden to test their
friendship with a hilarious round of the
shock therapy quiz and t was spilt honey
have an amazing weekend everyone bye
morgan bye
jamie yeah this question is to you i
know everything
jamie this is something only a close
friend would know
while he was at prince's house
andrew did something rather embarrassing
what was it
didn't you do a poo on the carpet
[Music]
incorrect
i vomited in on the carpet yeah
you vomited at prince's house
prince's house it was nerve-wracking no
it was like no we were at a party and
and i would i had drunk too much i don't
i can't hold alcohol very well and i and
i was in line for the toilet trying to
keep it down and the two most beautiful
actresses in the world were behind me
selma hike and penelope cruz and i was
like oh no i'm about to go and vomit
where they're about to go pee
and uh
and that's what happened